was geht hier ist heute spielen wir ein
ründchen lucky blogs das erklärt noch
mal eben für die liebe sturm war feld
gehörte dabei und du kannst alle blöcke
abbauen
diese lucky blogs daraus können tolle
sachen kommt und mit einem tollen sachen
kannst du die bösen gegner töten und ich
bin mir des xx ja aber es gibt richtige
op sachen wasser das dass du ganz feines
bekommen noch big stick das waren
shooter wahrscheinlich oder also das ist
halt alles verschneit und sturm electric
sheep shooter ja so ein bisschen sheep
geschockt passiert der komische scheiße
also wie viel schießt kann man schouten
ok alle weg aus bei mir fliegende
schweine herum also da passiert ziemlich
trist stehen das ist im interesse dieser
öffnet sich die krise intern nicht schon
in bar wo zyklen bin wie viel kann ich
kräften
also ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich hab's
ja schon gesagt das ganze spiel ist
ziemlich im inneren balance ist
eigentlich so lustig und wenn ich wenn
ich sterbe recht weg gemacht du darfst
kann herunterfallen und dort eine
relativ bei luca nicht luca
das ist halt so
leidigen einfach ok beleidigt das leben
für uns verbreitet der liebste locker
ist einfach nichts gewesen
probieren die mitte zu kommen wo es
nicht so gewesen die auf manche kosten
explodieren auch unter wasser
wieso die schweiz vom sachs muss jetzt
ja tut mir leid ohne müsse so arrogant
geworden
ich bin schon ganz schön wesentlich
möchte mich entschuldigen bei allen aber
abonniert wird oft trotzdem dann links
näher beschreiben
auf seinem kanal ich es ist ganz wichtig
abonnieren auf seinem kanal meine
freunde wertvoll und dann sehen wir
jetzt einfach irgendwann wieder mal zu
schauen ich sie warum ich habe eine
schule muss vorliegen die mitte zu bauen
so kaka der shooter erst probiert
abzuschießen
nein ich bin so dumm ich hasse das wenn
du die hand weg nimmst von der maus und
dann fällst du runter
neben zombie antrieb aqua oder junge
anton du ich hab den lucky barrois das
wurde oder es nämlich keinen spaß mein
freund der motor schon wieder oder oh
mein gott ich brenne ich brenne ich
meine wo kommt alter oder und hoher wie
nennt man es wenn man foto krebs das ist
nicht mal neu weil herbert grönemeyer
singt auch so schon bevor es war cool
herbert grönemeyer kennedy dutzi gott
sind zwar einfach erde und dann steht da
okay und politik ist ja ja da steht
drauf irgendwie nicht so nett ich hätte
sie wirklich die zuschauer von carl
krafft erkennt er an mal marica man kann
man ich weiß nicht wie fucking man diese
band aussprechen
kathrin nicht dass ich wüsste probieren
siehst du ja nur sagen wie das ensemble
sambo schlägt schon wieder leute dran
ist wahrscheinlich am rauchen trinken
jeden tag
hauptsache es ist minimal
ausbildungsniveau ich letztens zu einem
konzert von nan shan trossinger des
balkankriegs ich finde das cool ja
letztens erst auf so einen ganz ruhigen
konzert das erste mal und es war richtig
entspannend wieder was ist denn mit mir
essen möchte krankhafter von vor dem
satz zitieren
es ist so dass so manche wahrscheinlich
direkt sterben wird und das nicht so
hinkriegt kraft fehlen er hat es okay
leute wir probieren jetzt die letzte
runde vielleicht wird das heute nur 30
und lang das video aber ihr wisst ja
lucky bike orsons immer unberechenbarer
beweist dass ich sowohl die abgestimmt
du bist extra gut die ganze zeit das ist
schon wieder rein
bitte jetzt freunde sterbe ich nicht so
wie jetzt
und jemand genau die dass der mann von
ihr erhalte einfach 6
8 ich will einfach nur hoffen du wirst
schon wieder es ist komplett im wellness
und kotick das spiel aber ich habe
einfach die spd fiel oder denn mutter
ist nicht die ist nicht viel aber ich
hab's noch abwärts und 100 blogger wohl
drauf steht ja dieses megabit sind alle
unterschiedlich
und damit man sie nicht erkannt bestehen
oder joghurt schweine seitlich leine
legen
ich meine dass leute immer fragen ob man
die echten sind also ich dafür ja ja und
treue
hat irgendjemand schon mal auf einem
premium server leute gefällt da kann er
zum beispiel auch sein dass sturm waffe
mit l geschrieben ist oder sogar das hd
gibt auch einen der das hat dann sieht
das genauso aus zum beispiel christoph
stürmer fertig war der also anstatt nl
hat er dann großes team macht so
weidinger und dann wenn man bei wir sind
ja kein premium auf dem server und dann
wundern sich die blut und urin
ich habe meine das ist immer sehr
nützliches mit welches geht richtig
jemand nicht ganz neues ja gar nicht
mehr aus dem kasten soll ausgeliehen an
kopf oder so nur kopf in kraft dann
kannst du auch endlich mal nachdenken
aus dem richtigen schlag so was ja leute
ist es heute mal die der website
natürlich sehe ich bin nicht einfach nur
ein youtuber ich habe auch irgendwo
vorbildfunktion ja einmal das und auch
eine vorbildfunktion und ihrer
vorbildfunktion ist auf jeden fall schon
erfüllt leute wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
man schnell stoppt guckt klar nicht
videos wie man schnell stirbt ja und ich
probiere meine eigene akzente zu lassen
bis du wirst du bist was denn los ist
eigene akzente mein gott oh mein gott
titel des videos mir anschauen
dieses video have to watch hrw direktor
ist eine für watch video eigentlich ist
ja nicht bestehen wenn du dumm ist ist
so dumm man kann einfach nicht verzögern
weil es keines gibt dann fallen die
mitte gehen soll nicht im kopf ja wo
willst du denn nicht in der mitte doch
meine ich natürlich hast du bist bist du
denn mit ok dann tötet ihn jetzt nicht
wenn ich jetzt unbedingt dafür so schild
wir sind doch keine sachen mir jetzt
oder in der mitte habe ich hätte nicht
so teuer war muss 23 aber es gilt ich
habe ich habe mir sogar noch sieben
lucky dog übrig die kann mir zusammen
öffnen wenn du kommst möchte dankeschön
stehen dafür bis einfach meine tasche
danke aber die diamanten habe ich
eigentlich ist ich habe ich habe eine
komplette die rüstung und nur 13 stück
übrig wer genau okay ich werde darunter
geschossen wenn er nicht habe wurde
ich habe zwei gekillt direkt miteinander
bei dem bau läuft wie bei keiner anderen
aber davor die runden waren ja das tolle
gegend
übrigens haben die leute medicon tage
stehen haben was man so tolles machen
kann mit dem lucky star dass man da
diese diese blitze kasten kann und so
was ich sehr nützlich hier auf jeden
fall bist du dir ja ich sehe doch warte
mal ich kann nicht obwohl alles cool
direkt wird zu blamieren und geht der
sache ich kämpfe wird ihn nicht man darf
die kämpfe einfach nicht hin
ich kämpfe weiter
lappen doch weitergeht kurzzeit badekur
23 ich hab doch sagen für die ok ich las
sachen in der mitte fallen
die will ich nicht wenn ich die sachen
schenker gereist wie an so einer besuch
findet unter aller sau und unterlassung
mit dem lab keine studierende scheiße
ich frage würde ganzen anderen tut sind
warum braucht man bis zum verzaubern ich
hasse es ja es ist so behindert
sie gehen nicht auf die idee gekommen
oder oder oder oder ist irgendwie so ein
komischer
alter spielst du nicht wie ich ziehe
mich mit dir sein
das passiert möchte ich kenne
hast du denn aus ja dann schaue ich
richtig rum und ich verschreibe dem
titel den titel möchte ich gern pfeil
und bogen und fliegt ab wie stoppt jetzt
stoppte gott oh gott oh gott was soll
ich machen
die aufnahme ist auch ein klavier zu
ziehen
okay wir hätten definitiv kein muss ich
probiere ist amazon ins wort wenn es
nicht schafft ist auch nicht so wird
weil dann ist scheiße hier habt ihr es
macht mir spaß hier habt ihr die ganze
scheiße hier macht mir spaß damit noch
mal long und meine familie ernähren
kindern von irgendwelchen kinder die
familie kommt zum showdown
die griechen ich habe ihn perfekt ich
habe gott jetzt wird zwischen uns zum
showdown kommen
ich bin voll konzentriert weil ich
gerade voll konzentriert habe muss ich
jetzt komplett alleine in der mitte
gelassen die ganze zeit nur ist schon
klar
und das heißt du konntest maschinen wir
legen direkt los
ja genau
ja genau red back to back und mein gott
was diese pack ich konnte mich nicht
bewegen
unverdient gewonnen wenn ihr bei diesen
arschloch des unverdient gewannen der
beschreibung